Today,
at the turbine toll station,
near the French-Italian border,
we came with Eric Ciotti
to see in the field how
work the police,
the gendarmes who secure our borders.
We still see it
yesterday with the fact that the concessionary board,
at the request of the government,
refused the French the
possibility to decide on migration policy.
We wanted to give them back their word,
the power refuses it.
Well,
all this has consequences
concrete on the ground.
Here,
it is for several weeks
the difficulty for the police
to drive back automatically
illegal migrants who came from Italy.
From now on,
you have to do 1 readmission procedure
which is long and complicated.
And in case of a new migration crisis,
it is obvious that it will be
impossible to protect the border.
They are police officers,
of the gendarmes who confide that individuals however
dangerous and spotted as such,
are despite everything
released because it is not possible to keep them.
And the immigration pact,
yes,
is a missed opportunity to rebuild policy
European migration.
This will be the great challenge of the world to come.
We need to be strong to achieve this.
Our line in any case is clear,
protect Europe's external borders,
give a voice to the
French to keep control of our destiny